let's take you straight to New York now
where police are briefing media about an
arrest they've made concerning the
attack on a subway early on Tuesday
morning let's listen in John DeVito
special agent in charge ATF these are
the partners who have been working with
us from the first moment of this
incident and we have important
information to transmit today first I
would like to go to the mayor live from
Gracie Mansion
yeah
[Music]
my fellow New Yorkers
we got him
I cannot thank
the men and women the New City Police
Department enough as well as our federal
agents
our state police our First Responders
from the 9 11 operators
to
the various men and women from our
medical professions
we got him
and said to New Yorkers
we're going to protect the people of
this city
and apprehend those
who believe they can bring Terror to
every day of the audience and I wanted
to thank every day in the office who
called in tips who responded
who help those passengers who were
injured
33 shots
for less than 30 hours later
we're able to say
we got him
thank you commissioner for your
leadership the job well done
and now police commissioner of the city
of New York Keyshawn soul
good afternoon everyone and thank you
for being here
I am truly fortunate to Stand Here among
these extraordinary investigators and
federal Partners to make this
announcement moments ago Frank Robert
James was stopped on the street and
arrested by members of the New York City
Police Department
officers in response to a Crime Stoppers
tip stopped Mr James at 1 42 p.m at the
corner of Saint Mark's Place and First
Avenue in Manhattan he was taken into
custody without incident and has been
transported to an NYPD facility
he will be charged with committing
yesterday's appalling crime in Brooklyn
I want to commend all of the
investigators and analysts who took part
in this all hands on deck investigation
literally hundreds of NYPD detectives
worked doggedly during the last 30 hours
to bring this together
they did so in tandem with a vast number
of our law enforcement Partners
including those from the FBI NYPD joint
terrorism task force the ATF NYPD crime
gun Intelligence Center
and the regional task force led by the
United States Marshals service
we hope this arrest bring some Solace to
the victims and the people of the city
of New York
we used every resource at our disposal
to gather and process significant
evidence that directly links Mr James to
the shooting
we were able to shrink his world quickly
there was nowhere left for him to run
I like to turn it over to Chief James
essig for details of the investigation
so as you heard there an arrest has been
made in relation to uh Tuesday's attack
at a subway station
uh in Brooklyn New York City we can
cross over now to Gabriel Elizondo who
joins us uh in Brooklyn New York so a
fairly uh Swift arrest has been made in
this case
yeah it was just about 30 hours ago that
this gunman opened fire in a New York
City subway train shooting 10 people
injuring more than 20 police began an
intensive investigation immediately
after the shooting occurred they
released on Tuesday evening the name of
their main suspect Frank James released
a photograph of him and now here on
Wednesday afternoon police confirming
that they have taken Frank James a 62
year old man into custody police just
confirming that it was due to a tip that
they received on the tip line on his
whereabouts officers apparently saw him
on the streets approached him and
according to police took him into
custody without incident he will now be
booked in jail and we're awaiting his
first court appearance but clearly this
is a huge sigh of relief for millions of
New Yorkers who have been very in see
and anxious all day millions of people
that commute on subways just like the
one you see behind me the subway
stations like this knowing that this
mass shooting in New York City now the
main suspect according to police is in
custody and you heard from the mayor
there the first thing he said was three
words he said we got him we got them so
clearly a big sigh of relief here is
this massive Manhunt now ends with a
suspect you know under arrest uh Gabe I
know that investigators are not talking
about a motive yet but just remind our
viewers of what happened that morning
because it was rush hour when this
attack happened
yeah that's right to talk about the
motive they aren't releasing any
information about a motive because we
simply don't know it yet that's going to
come out probably in the coming hours
maybe days they have to interview uh the
suspect and but there's no obvious
motive he didn't leave a note he didn't
uh leave any sort of obvious motives but
that is clearly what's going to be on
everyone's mind what would drive someone
to do this uh he did leave a lot of
evidence at the scene there was a nine
millimeter handgun that was found at the
scene there was uh his credit card
including keys to a vehicle that was
registered in his name uh bottom line
though what happened on Tuesday was rush
hour in Brooklyn at a very busy train
station a subway station in Brooklyn uh
according to police Mr James uh the the
suspect now got on one of the train cars
was wearing a gas mask and he released
some sort of uh tear gas or gas bomb if
you will that caused Panic on the train
and then immediately he started opening
fire that led to Mayhem and pandemonium
10 people were shot many bleeding
profusely
many rushed out of the train car into
the station uh hundreds more leaving the
train station and that's when uh the
suspect fled and that's when this
massive Manhunt began for James now
James according to police uh his his
nearest address is where he lived were
uh Wisconsin and Pennsylvania but beyond
that we simply do not know much about
him but we should be getting more now
that he is under arrest in the coming
days getting more information all right
thank you for that Gabriel Elizondo
there live for us in New York